yeah iceland the polls are still hungry
for successes football is my religion
Magnus edenia legatee a truly a to the
public on safe here Aloha party
there are three million people in Wales
nine million sheep in Wales this doesn't
happen to us to stand on an
international stage and play football
better than some of the best teams in
the world mallu Bhatti yelu a big fish'
gone and her Marion getting you some of
my own those the avoid quality arts
we're not going to be reeling Thomas
manner i got or anything was for
watching the football with it is it is
changing my life
my name is era eat ganassa fish I'm from
Iceland and I live here in Paris for
over 10 years
I love to see the Eiffel Tower in the
morning it's absolutely beautiful
so storico wonderful romantic
we're only 329 thousand approximately so
it is relatively rare to meet my sonic
person I think so yeah they're surprised
they usually ask me a lot of questions
about volcanoes mostly and then
obviously now about our football team
I I hope and I think that we will get
into the quarterfinals that's I think
that's everybody's dream
je m'appelle a un niveau gem leaky
faucet sampling see ya boo kujan also on
a spot cosita New Year's Moscow can
compare i'm a lil one
cervical on foster ave to ski space s
inundation looky Marissa is Atlanta
bazooka Japan when it misspell okay I'm
not Valley News also persuade you
I think we haven't seen the end yes
after the Paris attacks we're very
likely to see more attacks however you
have to carry on living your life yes
you can attack our city yes you can
attack our people but we will still win
we're not afraid and I think that means
that's what it means to be Parisian
today 30 and evil heart of it it was in
the yeah but Robin and Ackley burn cream
forgot where these grapple Johnny bar
sauce pan MA Mary return saucepan
mountain barrier la parka woody scrubber
Johnny my name is Kate I am a Welsh
journalist living in Paris and of course
following at the fantastic progress of
the last football team in the year 2016
tournament the fact that whales have
done so well for me is an opportunity to
show the French and the whole of Europe
that you know whales exists it is not
part of England it is next door to
England it's a part of Britain but it's
not the part of England
well my name is Dominic Perkins and the
head chef at the bomb india pub in Paris
I work in an English pub fell because I
enjoy cooking so much I have lived in
France for ten and a half years I came
here to study French at the University
of London Institute in Paris I feel more
affinity towards French culture and
politics way of life than I do with
England there's a reason why I live here
and I don't live in England well I don't
think in English have any high
expectations what usually happens that
they perform well for about two games
and then one goes oh my god we can win
this thing and then then they'll get
knocked out on penalties somewhere
on this I've gotta Iceland this tiny
little country kind of coming up you
never know we might win if we get really
lucky that would be an incredible story
that I think nobody would ever forget
first of all it was my dream for like
the last 15 years to have a restaurant
I'm keeping this restaurant open because
it's the only athletic restaurant in
Paris and we're watching the game
altogether
eight percent of our country is here in
France today to support them and to be
one hundred percent behind them we're
extremely proud of our team the big
secret of the I sonic team is their
heart and the fact that they have
something to prove to the rest of Europe
that even though we're a small country
we can still go just as far as the other
countries
sabes que eres auntie concavity light
avenue pub Schmidt asanti comme cela
palani velu dompok teleku gmod oh no I
Nicola not have a bachelor brazing
katrin 0 on fina my name is Camilla
Barsky I'm both French and polish I'm a
book translator and I'm sporting polish
national team since I'm small kid
honestly football and literature
probably don't go together I'm really
struggling with that you know with both
patients too I have this moments that I
I should stop football just focused on
books and literature and somehow i'm
always getting back to it's a very basic
primitive emotion
best thing about polish team this year I
think is the confidence they finally
have during yours polish players were
scared about you know going through for
some big games now they actually work as
a team and believe that they can win
even against the big teams usual
resealable Allah balloon serum on those
keys no more symbolic a blue kazoo
Magnolia Cody burns equip and automated
miss receive an Tosh which you don't
only saw this panel is adorable do she
talked about she gazes with nearly
Portugal fond Oliver
Jake or Joe also it's a module amazing
only party for France at the rendezvous
mission valley is Cornell Elaine decrypt
area on the Christian when I do is in
million buco insula
people has a stereotype of French people
they think they are really romantic but
actually I found it it's not my name is
I Chen I'm from China and I came here
for further study
it was six years ago that was the first
time I start to watch the games some
things they really plays really dirty
the German team you have your own
strategy and this is one of the reason
why I start to like germinating mauricio
the chintala testa
janome andreia sono qua decir ishani
mamba so no oto antiqua a dell chain
todo el italiani vengono per la partita
and this is my my baby blue bar is my
baby
Italy is a team with many champion like
Abu fun like bizarrely like the hosts
are free free work champion of 206 and
if you want I show something to you this
is the ticket of the final in a 2006 and
i was in berlin and there was a winner
always when we play with Italy with a
reduction officially is really out for
you
germany and italy has been consistent
rivalry each other so this game is also
very important for both of the country i
hope that this time Germany could win
the game
it's even happier than last time I walk
I saw like a war club Germany warrior
war club because it's so hard I almost
got a heart attack I mean so excited and
like the penalty was amazing
as the historical moment for me the
first time ever like I saw them thank
you sir I was just like congratulations
it's battle day the Vikings are going to
battles or the goo ah and hopefully the
veterans will win I actually had a lot
of French people come up and tell me
that they wish that we would win because
they feel like we deserve it more we
worked harder for it and it's such a
dream for such a small country to go so
far and in a European competition it's
absolutely amazing
I came here for us just on vacation and
at the airport I met this beautiful
Frenchman and he asked me if I wanted to
come in a motorcycle ride around Paris
and of course you can't say no to that
and now 10 years later we're still
together we have three beautiful
children a tiny little chihuahua and a
beautiful house in the country
you know we're not losing me oh we were
already windows when we started so we're
good
gratulations my darling depends on the
game was discordant I don't know I'm
sorry we need you Lucy at the same time
yeah you're bright side always gonna
find the right side of everything is the
key
vanesio no final response camo camo
viera phones para mi fue con el final
like a 20 feet literally français ET duo
me vomit ropa de view on pants epic
alien final home balaton final to
transit ET le Roux cosmos a pecan picket
kami glass notice a compliment no more
partying generate a lan support Nicki
Post reporter Pelle Pelle nationality
vova ojos que la nacional de forma mone
de la blusa juice pour sa bad la
politique i want to be gareth bale okay
okay well how are you
red dragon it's it's not so much that
it's fearful but it's a powerful symbol
it breathes fire and I really think that
when Welsh people see the red dragon
this just a sense of patriotism and love
is he or is he not the most beautiful
man in the world a nice cookies wearing
Welsh colors what more do you want in a
man it's amazing
SMP explicado paseo por mas el mejor de
monde la gana de Bordeaux el parche
gotcha no se lo dudo footballs say right
position 0 in oconee papas con una vaca
fan non konkani tues paso moscone 07
still a mess a fine Olivia to so passive
except entre vous Molly favor same a
fashion emergency los pollitos important
so German danke a promise in touch the
magic glasses will get truly much
tutorial watch football of believable
you know last time we had a game on an
international platform like this it's 58
years ago there's no pressure to win now
that's the difference between us and the
big teams like Portugal and France and
Germany you know we never expected to
get this far
to see so many thousand people coming
from Wales you know on facebook on the
radio I've heard thousands of people are
making the trip so I couldn't be a
two-hour train writing Leon the not go
as well support my voice come what may I
don't care how much it costs I'm going
whatever the school the Welsh people
will probably be hugging the Portuguese
at none of the game if we win we'll
definitely be hugging the Portuguese
we're just there to enjoy ourselves and
just have a good game of football openly
but moving in a blue shows a I said the
word Santos is caught by the shame I
know your pc boo cadet integrant at the
picture Bridget major cool water control
box again jacuzzi a souvenir or since
its lucky trst what a sensible stable
troops in cass naumann sick if i become
a few day 10
keanu Lamarckian boot to monte de la
riva ma ke te pasa know who he's a mean
tweet a linear amake do budapest aangan
doozy
dog lettieri efficient vehicle demo /
you call a bachelor wedding
known as the wichita new dragon a paw
patroller population subscribe to
chewata population
how does that mean
super super money technically time oh
well don't rinse take you on I know
young male gallimore match emails but
I'm the only super as well is if I can
musique more in the wagon Islam
she was castle I'm all at once more fury
is a spell to cure a member named la
gana mana Franciscan treasure will be
City give the fossil fuel being opposite
the move is possible yep you have a
phenomenal
reversing of a credible match Shelley
peduzzi satin bikini swampers see
schedule a final hospital yeah if people
i know this become agony jonacani almani
Portuguese Appa deniliquin Gandhi keeper
known again he learned man comes the
swastika Incred click on the key fob
which one again g20 newest pokémon
asleep
my own inner voice go sell at Nagisa o
sweet o see basically she annoyed by to
form a sort of a school of hotel but no
portugal inclusive video system to
complicate
this kharl if you can't be jumped off
together suitable for city but
electricity kurumi again discussed
well phases important Viscusi sido
staged a coup yo hablo de Tory to the
Afghan easy super spa viscosity syllable
water like sir
jeebus alone let a simple Java cool LMAO
rach nice weather sélectionner still not
done be
yo voy a mrs. Impaler political esposa
kusama tamanna busco la padukas
Christian le palais de vez pero solo is
in sooner sipping oh man
boom Africa gang hey Gallo Flossie
message biscotti son KO nua pongo en la
voy hacer una gallo negaunee
so de una de una ganas de mucha agua
agua fadama de mi padre de gallo faucet
repair module mutiny la la viola da
gamba dobrim Avenue bakhtiari dong Gyu
Veronica cook
you
you